de toute façon c'est une mafia du mois
ce ne sont pas pour nous des petits
désagréments
c'est vraiment un crime à la nature
[Musique]
depuis plusieurs jours nous avions été
interpellé par des bruits de pro
sonneuse au loin on s'est aperçu qu'il y
avait des circulations de gros engins et
à voisins un matin il est venu chez nous
en demandant à mon mari est ce que tu as
vendu du bois parce que tu as des
bûcherons chez toi alors on a dit non
non pas du tout on n'a rien vendu
d'autant plus qu'on voulait léguer ce
beau patrimoine à nos enfants et petits
enfants
[Musique]
il leur a dit mais arrêter mais vous
êtes chez moi et les bûcherons de
répondre moi pas parler français moi pas
comprendre patron m'a dit toi kumo coût
des qui c'est votre patron à moi par
téléphone moi papier mois par crayon je
sais pas et comme il avait mon mari
avait aperçu un 4 4
pas très loin il a pris la plaque en
photo
[Musique]
et
la famille qui avait une petite
maisonnette il y avait 300 sapin qui
entourait ce charmant petit petit
paysage
il ya plus de sapin vous croiriez qu'une
tempête est passé y'a plus rien c'est
une coupe rase une compagnie
[Musique]
bon bah excusez moi je vais vous donner
40 euros par chaîne après 50 euros après
150 euros maintenant c'est 250 euros
mais il faut pas qu'on porte plainte
nous personnellement 7,35 chênes
centenaires qui ont été volés des
chaînes tout droit sans aspérités des
chaînes qui se vente aux enchères c'est
pas au mètre cube
ce sont des chaînes qui se vendent très
cher que nous souhaitions garder mais
nous notre préjudice n'a pas de prix et
préjudice à la nature non il y a eu une
source qui a été dévié et gravement
pollués il ya le gasoil et toute l'huile
qui s'est déversé dans ce ruisseau qui
épaulent lieu à une grande profondeur
avant les anciens pour séparer les
parcelles faisait des murs en pierres
sèches
tous ces murs ont été défoncées y a plus
d'animaux et c'est vraiment honteux non
seulement de piller des profs des petits
propriétaires
mais surtout c'est un grave
dommage à la nature et aux animaux
[Musique]
on a reçu des pressions moi même j'ai
été victime de menaces de mort et
partant de kobe dans ma même craché en
pleine figure
donc j'ai déposé plainte c'est
certainement un homme de main mais en
moi je ne baisse pas les bras je
continue
[Musique]
ou bien que les gens salert quand ils
voient ils découpent dans les forêts
parce que c'est peut-être pas forcément
des coupes qui sont autorisés et il faut
maintenant être très prudent et
s'alerter et être sur le qui-vive que
nous on va pas lâcher la faire on ne
peut pas tolérer ça c'est pas possible
[Musique]